hier ils avaient la même équipe
exactement la même équipe et on leur a
fait faire l'épreuve des poteaux alors
c'est une séquence qui a fait énormément
réagir en étant top 8 toute la soirée et
je vais vous dire dans un instant et
tout au long des missions vous allez
voir les éliminations de ses poteaux on
va d'ailleurs revenir au départ quand
les neuf chroniqueur était sur les
poteaux regarder un petit résumé de ce
qui s'est passé hier dans l'émission est
juste après je vous donnerai le premier
éliminé c'est parti pour la 3g mais qu
ils humilient canada mais la belle alors
c'est perdu c'est l'heure du vous
descendez mèche
[Musique]
l aube annick mathieu a perdu mathieu
déjà douze minutes sur marne où vous
allez retirer vos sacs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
il
que le voir il restait hier la fin de
l'émission 6 6 qui étaient déjà restés
sur le plateau près de deux heures
c'est une prouesse exceptionnelle kelly
vdo velits maxime gainey il y avait
également barreaux mais témoigne avait
jules verdez il y avait raymond il y
avait également
j'ai remis ma jambe exactement jean-mi
francesca ils étaient six
l'arrière-garde et qui était le premier
éliminé le sixième à être éliminé dans
koh lanta hier dans l'épreuve des
poteaux je vous le dis on a vécu un truc
c'est un exceptionnel et je me dirais
même historique aventure humaine une
vraie aventure humaine
[Musique]
c'est bien mon vrai qu'on va terminer
tout seul sans personne à oui évidemment
c'est vrai on pourra peut-être en chine
tout le monde disait on pourra piloter
huit ans
apprendre à chialer d'appartenir au tour
des séries la france comme la première
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ces séries t'as craqué au bout de
couleur 12h05 11h05 les pubs chantaient
et dansaient à nous jeter des boules de
papier donc c'est déjà énorme qualité
deux heures moi j'aurais bien voulu caps
blancs continuent à voter pour savoir
qui va gagner et kelly je vous lis comme
votre frère vous envoyer un message il
s'appelle comment votre frère il
s'appelle lucas et voulait que je gagne
lucas voulait qu'il vous gagnez comme
vous êtes la première fille je vous
offre un week-end avec votre frère au
week-end avec votre frère et voilà vous
nous raconterez de ça parce que c'est la
première fois héroïque vraiment deux
heures ça vous le savez une équipe
n'étiez plus n'étaient plus que 4 il
restait raymond gilles jean michel et
maxime regardez regardez combien de
temps ils sont restés et qui a perdu en
quatrième position
regarde
et lui va jamais bougé san marco
qu'entre ma peau laisse une peau propre
os pas flamand rose ou alors on a vu 30
jusqu'à a perdu élus kelly qui était la
première fille kelly et on va voir
ensuite on a vu on a vu l'élimination
s'il reste très bon il réussit michel il
reste gilles et y reste maxime
regardez j'ai été vraiment le 2 ml tu
pourras me ment des attaques si bien
évidemment
c'est vrai
si je prends un taxi
jamais bougé ça nous va
en contrepartie
votre album
os
j'attends
ramaroson
[Musique]
je me laissais tomber maman
les gaffes
des ambitions il va quitter jean michel
bardet peur de tomber donc il s'est
laissé tomber
c'est ça parce que je sentais plus doux
mais gens que j'avais l'écran sous la
voûte plantaire je mets ici jetons jouer
peut-être cassé quelque chose et plus de
force
2h09 pas au bout de vos surprises non je
vous le dis c'est incroyable ce qui
s'est passé ensuite pouvez pas savoir
les cherry pour le moment regarder koh
lanta ils étaient tous les chroniqueurs
départ ils étaient 10 maintenant ils ne
sont plus que trois regardez qui a
abandonné au bout de combien de temps
chez le psy ou la semaine dernière te
mets un pied plaît un peu probants
clotilde courau me et marc équilibrer le
corps la semaine dernière
[Musique]
je souffre un peu à des petits
mouvements mais je tiens en de l'oregon
jeu par les ménages
oh
pas ça va se passer
nous avons regardé hier il y avait des
preuves des poteaux les deux finalistes
à maxime gay ni gilles verdez ils sont
restés plus de cinq heures sur les
poteaux d'aller découvrir combien de
temps ils sont restés et surtout qui a
été le grand gagnant qui va gagner le
week-end avec moi et valérie bénaïm et
la personne de son choix
regardez
[Musique]
sert il je crois que j'ai écouté le
pompier parce qu'il me dit que je suis
resté trop longtemps
bravo maxime de beaucoup de symboles et
messieurs merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils emporteront plein